[Music]
ever since I was a young kid my grandpa
tried to instill it in me that the coal
company is not your friend
that they're going to exploit you
they're going to squeeze every bit of
value out of you that they can and
they're going to leave you broken
all you need to do is look at this
bottle of water that I brought with me
today Congressman Carter I talked about
orange water none of us would drink this
they told the people don't let your kids
play in it and don't let your animals
drink from
Pennsylvania
there are roughly 600 000 Acres of Mines
left to be reclaimed and as they sit
they create more pollution have more
erosion issues and other problems
because they're not being maintained
the death toll in Kentucky continues to
rise following what the governor called
the worst flooding disaster he has ever
seen there's a federal law that if you
mine coal you have to clean up the land
when you're done and a lot of companies
have found ways to avoid doing that
bankruptcy seems to provide coal
companies a way to shed a lot of
liability look there's a stigma
associated with filing for chapter 11
because people confuse it with your
going out of business we're not going
out of business we're going to
restructure this is a story about how
big coal companies avoid their
responsibility to clean up their old
Minds
[Music]
my name is Junior walk I'm 32 years old
I work for coal River Mountain watch
[Music]
essentially what I do is go out and
document coal mining operations
usually with video about drone
try to find things that the coal
companies are doing that goes against
environmental regulations like making
roads in places they're not supposed to
blasting in places they're not supposed
to timbering where they're not supposed
to
and get them in trouble on that
[Music]
so welcome this is the coal River
Mountain watch office when I was a kid
it was like a pizza place but we've been
here since like 2014.
our main mission is to be a thorn in the
side of the coal industry we are going
to keep on them until they're out of
here
there was a bridge owned by a coal
company that had collapsed into the
river and I called it in and they made
them clean it up
foreign
this is the Brushy Fork impoundment
holds back 7.8 billion gallons of cold
slurry it's a lake of toxic waste
the Appalachian mountains are beautiful
I mean being up in the mountains it's
bright bright green trees and almost
vertical mountains Rising away from the
road
[Music]
at the same time the presence of coal
There is almost overwhelming I mean it's
really everywhere
[Music]
there are coal conveyors basically big
pipes with conveyor belts that run over
the road so you're just driving along
and then there's just a lot of big tubes
running over the road
there's coal trucks
and are really really loud and really
big that go by seems like almost like
once a minute
[Music]
some of the small towns we stopped in
there was coal littering the side of the
road
because so many coal trucks go by the
coal shakes off the top of them and
there was just little pieces of coal
along the road
a lot of people we talked to did feel
like we live in such a beautiful place
and it's really been severely damaged by
the coal companies
people talked about growing up with
family members Gathering ginseng or
gathering firewood or hunting in the
woods and that now some of those areas
are just gray moonscapes where they
can't do any of those things
this is uh the Twilight complex which is
Lexington Coal Company operation
it's a massive mountaintop removal site
that is a chunk of Raleigh County and
Boone County
initially it was a massive energy
operation and then sold to Alpha
then I suppose Alpha has offloaded it
onto some company known as uh Lexington
because they don't want to bother with
the the Reclamation responsibilities up
there
this is the site that Lexington is
supposed to be you know reclaiming and
they're not there's no equipment out on
that site no work being done whatsoever
I mean it essentially hasn't been
touched since Alpha had it
first got interested in this story when
I was a bankruptcy reporter
coal companies went through a big string
of bankruptcies around 2015 2016.
and during that time they offloaded or
shed a lot of Labor obligations promises
that they'd made to pay workers and
those were mostly picked up by the
federal government so I kind of had in
my head that you know coal companies and
their obligations was an interesting
area
bankruptcy seems to provide coal
companies a way to shed a lot of
liability
and come out the other side as a
profitable company that still holds
Minds
when coal companies go bankrupt any
other legal actions against them are
often stopped
so if we find a water pollution issue
and it's with a coal company that isn't
bankruptcy there's often little we can
do for citizen enforcement of water
pollution issues against a Coal Company
that's in bankruptcy foreign
we became focused on a company called
Alpha met Alpha metallurgical resources
because it's a really big company it's
one of the biggest coal companies in the
U.S because it's shed a really large
number of permits and a mine permit is
what a company has that allows them to
mine coal on a specific piece of land
and attached to the permit is also the
responsibility to clean up the land
the story with Alpha is they were doing
really well for a while they were buying
other coal companies they were mining a
lot of coal they were making a lot of
money but around 2015 low natural gas
prices under cut coal and that helped
push companies like Alpha and other cool
companies into bankruptcy
pretty soon after the bankruptcy Alpha
passed on its used up minds or mines
that had less coal in them to smaller
companies and along with those mines
went the obligation to clean up the land
so over the past
decade or so really since about 2015
when several companies large companies
went bankrupt we've seen a phenomenon of
companies shedding their liabilities
essentially they will sell their good
Minds that still have coal to mine to
companies that want those minds and then
they will sell their other Minds that
often only need Reclamation and may have
a lot of liability to other coal
companies who agree to take them on
usually because the original companies
are paying them to do so and we've seen
several rounds of that happen it's kind
of like a game of hot potato where we're
just waiting to see what Coal Company is
going to be left with the mine when they
eventually run out of money and can no
longer find another Coal Company to take
them on Alpha Natural Resources
announced the transfer of some mostly
idle mining properties in West Virginia
Kentucky and Tennessee to a company
called Lexington Coal Company almost all
the big coal companies in the US have
used a similar Playbook the big mining
companies like Alpha transferred a lot
of their permits to smaller companies
companies like Lexington black Jewel
pristine and then those smaller
companies have often racked up a really
large number of environmental violations
so when Alpha and Lexington announced
the big transfer they said that they
could accelerate Reclamation on a
five-year timeline
five years have passed and not a lot has
been done
out of about 230 permits only 40 have
been cleaned up
foreign
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
so when I was a senior in high school I
went to work for Massey Coal Company
because I realized that you kind of need
money to go to college in this country
and I didn't have money and neither did
my family so I went to work with my dad
at the elk run cold processing plant
I was just doing general maintenance
some days wasn't so bad they just have
me like cutting grass
but some days I'd be Waist Deep In Cold
slurry with a high-powered pressure hose
I felt like I was taking my life into my
own hands every time I come to work
so I quit that job and by the time I was
19 a friend of the family offered me a
position as a security guard on a
mountaintop removal site
but within the first week of me working
up there watching that Machinery tear
down that mountain for 12 hours a day
made me feel like that money I was
putting in my wallet was blood Money
because it was
I mean the things I went through when I
was a kid of cold trucks rumbling by
your house all hours of the night cold
trains you know dust bad water all that
I knew that the people who were living
down below that mine site that I was
working on were going through the same
things
the underground coal mine near my
parents house in Eunice
you can just see coal pouring right off
the belt line into the coal pile you can
see uh an excavator loading up a coal
truck
[Music]
when I was a real young kid we had well
water at this place and massing energy
at the time started getting rid of their
coal slurry by pumping it into an old
abandoned underground coal mine on this
same Hillside that this new coal mine is
now in
that ended up making its way through the
groundwater through the aquifer and
getting into our well and our well water
at that house was red for years and
smelled absolutely disgusting
yeah there's crap over here pretty much
ruined my childhood home
so that's great
in these underground deposits West
Virginia has cold enough to last the
nation for Generations
coal really powered the U.S coal was
used to forge weapons during the
Revolutionary War
but for most of the first 200 years coal
was mined in the U.S there was no real
regulations or laws that would make
companies clean up the land after they
were finished mining
that changed in 1977 with the surface
mining control and Reclamation Act
smackra I recommend a three-phase
program at the federal label one is a
law that says industry cannot strip mine
land unless it can restore it to its
original utility and natural purpose
[Music]
so the federal surface mining law spells
out certain requirements about returning
the land to its approximate original
Contour
so that means putting some of that
excess dirt and rock back kind of
building the mountain back up
they would have to re-vegetate the site
or add whatever infrastructure might be
needed for post-minding land use so in a
lot of cases it would be replanting
forests but it could also be building
infrastructure
they also have to address water problems
during mining they control their water
runoff with sediment ponds so that
they're not letting polluted water leave
the mines but during Reclamation they
are required to get that mine back to
the state where it's no longer producing
polluted water
most companies would claim that they're
doing good Reclamation and they're doing
it as quickly as they can but from what
we've seen on the ground we see mines
that sit on reclaimed for close to a
decade so those mines aren't being
reclaimed and they are not producing
coal they're just sitting idled and as
they sit they create more pollution have
more erosion issues and other problems
because they're not being maintained
foreign
ER tonight of the nation's latest
extreme weather disaster
it's a death toll in Kentucky continues
to rise following what the governor
called quote the worst flooding disaster
he has ever seen there are hundreds of
unaccounted four people minimum
the flooding that we've seen in central
Appalachian recent years as weather
events get more extreme that flooding
has been exacerbated by the presence of
these unroclaimed surface mines because
the mines that haven't been re-vegetated
they can't hold water like a natural
Forest can
one of the greatest sources of
frustration is that while there are laws
on the books that actually require the
coal companies to do remediation and to
clean up some of the damage that this
process does those laws are rarely
enforced and there are millions and
millions of dollars in fines that have
been leveled levied against these coal
companies that they haven't paid so the
sad truth is that the cost of this
damage is borne by the people who live
in these areas
it was a really difficult story to
report some of the challenges were
people in the region people in West
Virginia and Kentucky were often pretty
reluctant to speak about what they'd
been through or how their homes had been
damaged
coal provides many of the jobs or at
least it has historically in the region
so people felt like they'd be speaking
out against their uncle or cousin or dad
who worked in a coal mine or they'd be
getting dirty looks at a grocery store
but I think one moment when it felt like
the story really clicked into place as
when I talked to a man named miles
Hatfield
he lives in Eastern Kentucky
he lives sort of Downstream or downhill
from an old Alpha mine called love
branch
and the mine was transferred to
Lexington as part of the big as part of
the big asset transfer
and he complained even before the
transfer that there was flooding onto
his land
it had made his yard into sort of a red
Marsh
but the transfer to Lexington went
through and just as Alpha had not
cleaned up the land or stopped the
flooding of his home Lexington didn't
stop it either and he ended up having to
move
to me that was a perfect example of a
mind that had been owned by Alpha
and transferred to Lexington and not
cleaned up by anyone
and then was hurting someone that lived
right next to it
at that time I think it was named Alpha
but they switched back and forth
to my understanding they jump in and out
of
bankruptcy a lot to avoid some things
the Water started coming through
probably within a year after they quit
mining
my dining room kitchen fell in
there was no warning when it fell
in a bed of an eye I was in four foot of
water
which I didn't know was there
until it went in
it took me about 20 minutes to get out
of the hole that I was in
and I went upstairs told my wife she
couldn't believe it she come down and
where we did have a kitchen and dining
room didn't have it anymore
when that floor fell that took all the
water lines out so it didn't have water
couldn't really live down here so we got
lucky and got to rent a house about a
mile down the road there
but uh there's nothing to do up here I
keep the grass cut that's about it
I would appreciate if they would step in
and take care of what damage they did
they can't deny it because the
scientists they were here three
different times but they did say this
was from that coal mine they said it was
their water that's done this damage
not all coal companies are that bad
just some of them get the coal get out
[Music]
the problem with Smacker at this point
is that the requirements for Reclamation
are unclear and there isn't enough money
available to do the Reclamation it's
11.3 billion dollars that taxpayers are
paying for cool companies that went out
of business and did not leave money
around for the cleanup of what they left
behind
it's really easy for coal companies to
convince State Regulators to give them a
lot of leeway for how long it takes them
to do reclamation
the dep Department of Environmental
Protection here in West Virginia is a
state agency and as such They're ran by
the state government well who in this
state runs the state government it's the
coal industry and so in that way the
coal industry is much like a
self-regulating entity
so we're going up K Ford mountain right
now
really K food is a perfect example to
show folks of how Reclamation is a farce
because there's no way you can build
back one of the most biologically
diverse ecosystems on the entire planet
with bulldozers and the same Hydro seed
you see on the sides of interstates
hydroseed it's a grass seed mixed with
fertilizer and like chopped up newspaper
essentially but that stuff will grow on
literally anything you could spray it on
my desk and it'd be ready to cut with a
lawnmower next week
this is all the Reclamation or
remediation work that they're even
liable for so it looks pretty awful if
you ask me
the way the laws are structured if you
dig ginsang before the first of
September that's Federal time that's big
big trouble because it's a rare plant
it's endangered but these coal companies
all year round can blow off the tops of
these mountains some of the most Lush
dense forests I've ever seen in my life
you know some of the most Prime ginseng
habitat in the entire planet just
totally turned into
what amounts to a parking lot
the mountain may not be able to be put
back exactly like it once was
but people can do good Reclamation and
good Reclamation is unquestionably
better than no reclamation
so we would like to see good Reclamation
done at all of these mines
[Music]
a lot of these mines can become
productive for us again
but it takes effort and time and money
to do that and a lot of the coal
companies want to avoid putting that
much effort in
I think that is very likely there will
need to be Federal funding to cover at
least some of the Reclamation that needs
to be done
most people feel like coal is on a
decline
we're shutting down coal plants in the
U.S the idea is that we'll be using less
and less coal since it's such a dirty
fossil fuel
that said we're in an energy crisis
right now and there's a lot of coal
being mined
a lot of these companies are seeing
record profits
Alpha for example is doing great its
stock is up uh over 700 percent from
when it left bankruptcy
[Music]
[Music]